i don't sound like that okay
my name is alfredo crossman chavez jr
i've been teaching
gym for five years now hi my name is
anisha kane and i've been a gym teacher
for 14 years
do i use tick tock yes i do at first i
did not
i'm not gonna say i was anti-tic toc i
was just like i don't know how to
maneuver through this app
i don't generally tic-tac i figured
after instagram
when snapchat and tick tock started i
said you know what we gotta leave
something to the kids it's too much when
i was a kid and i was taking gym
we used to roast some of it might be
really good some of it might be like oh
coach so i'm excited i'm excited to see
what these kids
think and what they got to say let's get
cracking
the accuracy i really love this video
it's the hard thing for me though
because
us coaches like to call this the
tyrannosaurus rex army you're going here
code
pop your arm pump your arm there are so
many different styles of runners
you can tell the arm flailers they're
like the lazy kids don't really feel
like running and then you have those who
like
our own track team or just you know hell
athletic and they want to outdo each
other so
johnny johnny get up this is why you're
fast
yeah this is why you're fat
[Music]
no teacher would ever ever there's your
job hi
goodbye most unemployment but it's
hilarious i noticed the prank well i
if i was her son i would have closed the
zoom like mom no you're bugging you
can't mind
you can't do that whenever i was in gym
class
i would tell my teacher that my back was
hurting because it wasn't i didn't want
to run the mile
and then my teacher asked me she was
like do you have proof
and i was like sorry did you want me to
pull out my spine and show you where the
pain is
the rp teacher out there who throw
people into the mile
they don't train the kids for it get the
kids well prepared for it so i feel for
him if he's in that particular
environment but
if he's not though you know what i'm
saying kids kiss me lying about them
injuries man you gotta wash them gotta
watch them okay
first of all we have to ask for notes
if there's a type of medical situation
and we know you're lazy
we know you don't wanna run cause we
were in gym we were lazy and we didn't
wanna run
so we know what your game plan is sir
don't be calling us the b word boom this
is where you'll come every single day
before class starts
this is the area where you will be
changing where did i say you guys will
be changing
that we need to change in here but i was
just wondering exactly you change
here in this locker room if i catch a
single one of you guys
changing in the bathroom stalls
everybody in this class will be running
15
extra laps okay every gym teacher's go
to is always
wax i mean the bathroom sauce is there
for you to change why can't we use them
you come on now i don't sound like that
okay do i sound like that
but i don't mind honestly if a person is
uncomfortable and they want to get
dressed in the bathroom
i don't really have a problem with that
i've never really known teachers to trip
off of that because i've never ever had
a student ask me that they just do what
they do
all right next video doing the pacer
test today i want all my boys to line up
right here on this
white line i can get down on all fours
and crawl from this
end of the gym to the other in the time
it takes between the first
lap beat i will show you right now get
ready watch me
hey yo shirley said i got a point to
prove and i'ma prove it today yo
i have not done that before but i have
sped walked the first slap to show kids
about pace but
low-key the pace was kind of like cool
for me pacer was like the fun test like
start off slow good up fast you always
be in competition with your friends like
i never had a problem with pacer right
this is definitely something that
happens in gym class
we have to demonstrate what it is the
you know activity is supposed to look
like in order to ensure that you can do
it properly
she's clowning us but i have i've done
that i've experienced that as teaching
these tick tocks were so much fun they
were really funny
it does encourage me to watch more tic
toc videos because they're fun they'll
be able to go on and download the app
and just
be a looky little i won't be posting
very much without
getting my look on it and see what you
guys are going on these are fun they
were fun
overall thoughts is they were funny they
were hilarious honestly very relatable
especially to my past experiences as a
kid growing up
love the laughter love the creativity by
the students get your laps three laps
[Music]
you